Now that we've registered our weather
provider in the Android manifest,
it's time to begin coding
our weather provider.
This is the final and most involved step
in implementing our content provider.
We'll be filling out these core
content provider functions.
Except for onCreate,
which we've already done for
you, we've added an instance
variable for our data base helper.
We initialize this in
our onCreate function.
We will use this database helper in
most of the content provider methods.
The first of the content provider
methods that we will look at is getType.
Implementing the functional version of
getType isn't strictly necessary for
our application.
But it's a nice way to review what
uris we're planning to handle.
We partially filled out
the getType function for you.
We use the urimatcher we built
earlier to match the given uri
against the expressions
we've compiled in.
For each match, we return the types that
we've defined in the weather contract.
Remember that the key information that
this conveys, is weather the content uri
will be returning a database cursor
containing a single record type item, or
multiple records type directory.
Content providers can also be used
to return other kinds of data
than just database cursors.
For example, if we wanted the content
provider to return JPEG images for
a content uri, we would have this
function return the standard mime type,
image/jpeg.
Let's un comment the testGetType
test from within TestProvider.
This will get us ready for
the next coding exercise.